what is wisdom
why do we long for it
how do we and where do we find it what
is it intelligence is what you use to
solve your problems as i was just
describing
rationality is
how you use your intelligence to
overcome the problems
of self-deception that emerge when
you're trying to solve your problems so
it's that matter problem
and then the issue is do you have just
one kind of knowing
i think you have multiple ways of
knowing and therefore you have multiple
rationalities
and so wisdom is to coordinate those
rationalities so that they are optimally
constraining and affording each other
so in that way wisdom is rationally
self-transcending rationality
right so life
is a kind of process where you
jump from rationality to rationality and
pick up a village of rationalities along
the way that then turns into wisdom
yes if properly coordinated you
mentioned framing yes
so
what is framing is that a set of
assumptions you bring to the table in
how you see the world how you
reason about the world
yeah how
how you understand the world
so it depends what you mean by uh
assumptions if it by assumption you mean
a proposition
representational or rule i think that's
much more downstream
from relevance realization i think
relevance realization
refers to
um
again constraints on
how you are paying attention
and so
for me
talking about framing is
talking about
this process you're doing right now of
salience landscaping
what's salient to you
and how is what's salient constantly
shifting in sort of a dynamic tapestry
and how are you
shaping yourself to the way that
salience landscaping is aspectualizing
the world shaping it into aspects for
interaction for me that is a much more
primordial process
than any sort of belief we have and
here's why
if we mean by beliefs you know a
representational proposition
then we're in this very problematic
position
because then we're trying to say that
propositions are ultimately responsible
for how we do relevance realization
and that's problematic because
representations presuppose relevance
realization
so i represent this as a cup
the number of properties it actually has
and that i even have epistemic access to
is combinatorial explosive
i select from those a subset
and how they are relevant to each other
insofar as they are relevant for me this
doesn't have to be a cup i could be
using it as a hat i could use it to
stand for the letter v
all kinds of different things i could
say this was the 10th billion object
made in north america
right
representations presuppose relevance
realization they are right they are
therefore dependent on it which means
relevance realization isn't bound to our
representational structures
it can be influenced by them but they
are ultimately dependent on relevance
realization let's define stuff
relevance realization yes what are the
inputs and the outputs of this thing
what is it what are we talking about
what we're talking about is how you are
doing something very analogous to
evolution
so if you think about
that adaptivity isn't in the organism
or in the environment but in a dynamical
relation and then what does evolution do
it creates variation and then it puts
selective pressure and what that does is
that changes the niche constructions
that are available to a species it
changes the morphology
you also have a loop it's your sensory
motor loop
and what's constantly happening is there
are processes within you that are
opening up variation and also processes
that are putting selection on it and
you're constantly evolving that sensory
motor loop so your you might call your
cognitive fittedness which is how you're
framing the world is constantly evolving
and changing i can give you two clear
examples of that one
right your autonomic nervous system
parasympathetic and sympathetic the
sympathetic system is biased
to trying to interpret as much of
reality as threat or opportunity
the parasympathetic is right is biased
to trying to interpret as much of the
environment as safe and relaxing and
they are constantly doing opponent
processing there's no little man in you
calculating your level of arousal
there's this dynamic coupling opponent
processing between them that is
constantly evolving your arousal
similarly your attention you have the
default mode network task network the
default mode network is putting pressure
on you right now to mind wander to go
off to drift right and then the task
focus network is selecting out of those
possibilities the ones that will survive
and go into and so you're constantly
evolving your attention okay so there's
a natural selection of ideas that a
bunch of systems within you are
generating and then
you use the natural selection what is
the selector the the object that you're
interacting with the glass
relevance realization
once again you just describe how it
happens yes you didn't describe what the
hell it is
so what's the goal what are we talking
about so relevance realization is
how you interact with things in the
world try to make sense of yes make
sense of why they matter what they mean
to you to your life yes and notice the
language you just used you're starting
to use the meaning in life language good
or bad that's good okay that's good so
what that what what does that
evolution of your sensory motor
loop do
it it
it gives you
and here i'll use the term for marlo
ponte it gives you an
optimal grip on the world
so let's use your visual attention again
okay here's an object
how close should i be to it
is there a right what you want to do
with it exactly exactly
so you have to evolve
your sensory motor loop
in order to get the optimal grip that
actually creates the affordance of you
getting to a goal that you're trying to
get to
yeah but you're describing physical
goals
of manipulating objects but
is so this applies
the task the process of relevance
realization is not just about getting a
glass of water and taking a drink no
it's about
falling in love
yeah of course what else is there well
there's uh
there's obvious between those two
options i can show you how you're
optimally gripping in an abstract
cognitive domain
okay
so a mammal goes by and most people will
say there's a dog
now why don't they say
they might but typically you know
probabilistically they'll say there's a
dog they could say there's a german
shepherd there's a mammal there's a
living organism there's a police dog
why that why there why do they stop
ellen or rush call these basic level
well what you find is that's an optimal
grip because it's it's getting you the
best overall balance between similarity
within your category
and difference between the other
categories it's allowing you to properly
fit to that object insofar as you're
setting yourself up to well i'm getting
so as many of the similarities and
differences i can on balance because
they're in a trade-off relationship that
i need in order to probably interact
with this mammal
that's optimal grip not right it's at
the level of your categorization
you evolve these models
of the world around you
and on top of them you do stuff like you
build representations like you said yes
what's the salience landscape salience
meaning
attention landscape
so salience is what
grabs your attention
or
what results from you directing your
attention so i sl clap my hands that's
salient it grabs your attention your
attention is drawn to it as bottom up
but i can also say you left big toe
and now it's salient to you because you
directed your attention towards it
that's top down and again
opponent processing going on there so
whatever stands out to you what grabs
your attention what arouses you what
triggers at least momentarily some
affect towards it that's how things are
salient
what salience i would argue is is how a
lot of unconscious relevance realization
makes information relevant to
working memory
that's when it now becomes
online
for direct sensory motor interaction
with the world so you think the salience
landscape the ocean of salience extends
into the subconscious mind
i think relevance does but i think when
relevance is recursively processed
relevance realization such that
it passes through sort of this higher
filter
of working memory and has these
properties of being globally accessible
and globally broadcast then it becomes
the thing we call salience look that's
that's that's really good evidence
there's really good evidence for my
colleague at u of t
university of toronto lynn hasher that
that's what working memory is it's a
higher order relevance filter that's why
things like chunking will get way more
information through working memory
because it's basically
making
it's basically monitoring how much
relevance realization has gone into this
information usually you have to do an
additional kind of recursive processing
and that tells you by the way when do
you need consciousness when do you need
that working memory and that salience
landscaping it's when you're facing
situations that are highly novel
highly complex and very ill-defined that
require you to engage working memory
okay got it so
relevance realization is in part the
thing that constructs that basic level
thing of a dog when you see it when you
see a dog you call it a dog not a german
shepherd not a mammal
not a
biological meat bag it's a dog
wisdom
yes so what is wisdom
if we return
i i think as part of that we got to
relevance realization
and then wisdom
is is a
accumulation of rationalities
he described the rationality as
a kind of uh starting from intelligence
much of puzzle solving and then
rationalities like the meta problem of
puzzle solving and then what wisdom is
the meta meta problem of puzzle solving
yes in the sense that
um the meta problem you have when you're
solving your puzzles is that you can
often fall into self-deception you can
miss self-deception right right so
whereas
knowledge overcomes ignorance uh wisdom
is about overcoming foolishness if what
we mean by foolishness is self-deceptive
self-destructive behavior which i think
is a good definition of foolishness
and so
what you're doing
is you're doing this recursive relevance
realization you're using your
intelligence to improve the use of your
intelligence and then you're using your
rationality to improve the use of your
rationality that's that recursive
relevance realization i was talking
about a few minutes ago think about a
wise person
they come into highly
often messy
ill-defined complex situations usually
where there's some significant novelty
and what can they do
they can zero in on what really matters
what's relevant and then they can shape
themselves salience landscaping to
intervene
most appropriately to that situation as
they have framed it that's what we mean
by a wise person and that's how it
follows out of the model i've been
presenting to you so when you see
self-deception i mean part of that
implies that it's intentional
part of the mechanism of cognition
you're
modifying what you should know
for some purpose
is that is that how you see the word
self-deception no
because i belong to a group of people
that think the model of self-deception
as lying to oneself
ultimately makes no sense
because in order to lie to you i have to
know something you don't and i have to
depend on your commitment to the truth
in order to modify your behavior
i don't think that's what we do to
ourselves
i think and i'm going to use it in the
technical term and thank you for making
space for that earlier on i think we can
[ __ ] ourselves which is a very
different thing than lying
you